Speaker 1: All right.
So one more sort of Kerry Lake story, but
it's also a Tulsi Gabbard story.
I don't know that I have to rehash the entire
story, but Tulsi Gabbard is a former Democratic
congresswoman.
She ran for president back in 2020 for the
Democratic primary.
And at the time, I told you guys, this is
not really a leftist.
This is a grifter.
This is not an interesting candidate.
She's not bringing interesting ideas.
She's just bamboozling people.
And many in my audience understood that.
Some did not.
And they said, Tulsi is the last real liberal.
She's truly the anti-war candidate.
She's truly this, that the other thing.
Okay.
Obviously untrue.
Cut to last week talks, he says.
I'm no longer a Democrat.
And in her speech leaving the Democratic Party,
she lists a whole bunch of different conspiracy
theories anti-white, racism, wokeism, an elitist
cabal that's in control.
It is like it's almost like QAnon stuff.
But she's an independent now.
She's a centrist and she's tagged, blah, blah,
blah, blah.
Okay.
Who's she campaigning for?
Last night, Kerry, like.
Kerry like Tulsi Gabbard, widely promoted
as showing up in support of Kerry, like one
of the most extreme candidates running in
2022 who has a chance to win?
I will tell you a little bit about that in
a moment.
But here are Tulsi and Kerry throwing bouquets
at each other.
Speaker 5: I am so blown away.
They said, we have a good crowd tonight.
This is a massacre.
I feel like a rock star up here, Tulsi.
You are really standing.
And you know, it's amazing the young Republicans
are not just the future.
They are the.
Speaker 4: Republican Party, the new.
Unidentified: Republican.
Now.
We're going to take a listen.
Speaker 4: Yeah.
Speaker 1: Tulsi Gabbard, who wants us to
believe that she is no longer part of the
Democratic Party, but she's still a centrist.
She still holds many progressive or at least
left leaning values, and she sees the good
of both sides in all this stuff.
One of her first acts as an independent, having
left defiantly and because of her principles
and values, left the Democratic Party.
One of her first acts is to show up in support
of Carrie Lake, who led Anti-Mask rallies.
Anti-Mask Mask Guides told a group of Republican
retirees she was preemptively, prophylactically
taking hydroxychloroquine to avoid getting
COVID 19.
That's something Carrie Lake said to people.
Carrie Lake said that if she becomes governor,
she will work to have hydroxychloroquine and
ivermectin produced in Arizona to make it
easier to get people those lifesaving COVID
drugs, which, of course, don't do anything
to help when you have COVID, as demonstrated
by actual medical trials.
She accused Joe Biden and Democrats of having
a, quote, demonic agenda.
She's doing the demonic stuff.
And Tulsi goes, Now that I'm a clear thinking
independent, I'm going to go and support Carrie
Lake.
Carrie Lake expressed support for banning
both surgical and medication abortions outright
in Arizona.
And, of course, Carrie Lake for nearly two
years has been a leading voice arguing that
Trump won the 2020 election when he very clearly
and obviously lost.
Carrie Lake is a disgusting ideologue and
extremist reactionary.
And now that Tulsi Gabbard is seeing the world
more clearly because she's no longer part
of the Democratic Party, she chooses to go
and say, Here's who I'm supporting.
Carrie Lake.
Absolutely disgusting.
And I've been hearing from dozens of our viewers
over the last week since Tulsi bailed on the
Democratic Party, dozens of our viewers saying,
David, I fell for it.
I fell for it.
And I feel so stupid now.
It was so obvious, guys.
Tulsi Gabbard was not what she claimed to
be.
And now she's campaigning for Kerry.
Like, we'll have these clips, by the way,
that I played on our Instagram, which you
can find by searching Instagram for David
Pakman show.